Bueno definitivamente estas acusaciones
mutuas entre ambos países sobre la
voladura de La Represa
novaka va a cambiar el rumbo de la
guerra por cuanto pues la la llamada con
su ofensiva que se venía anunciando por
parte de Ucrania desde hace muchas
semanas para la recuperación de algunos
territorios que están en manos de Rusia
Al otro lado del río niáper pues
prácticamente va a afectar más a los
ucranianos que a los rusos evidentemente
la La Represa va a inundar igualmente
Muchos de los lugares
donde las tropas rusas están pero por lo
menos le va a permitir a las tropas
rusas poder frenar esta contra ofensiva
que se venía anunciando desde hace mucho
tiempo Igualmente las tropas rusas van
se van a ver afectadas porque tampoco
van a poder avanzar sobre lo que
pretendían entonces aquí los dos en
realidad al final de cuentas están
perdiendo la posibilidad de poder
continuar por un lado unos recuperar el
territorio en el caso de Ucrania y Rusia
tratar de continuar en la conquista
territorial como ha venido haciéndolo y
que ha habido pues Lamentablemente hasta
el momento un estancamiento de la guerra
que se va a grabar al final de cuentas
con las consecuencias que está teniendo
esta situación de la voladura de La
Represa Nova crajoca a propósito de este
tema y usted lo comenta Rusia acusa a
Ucrania de volar esta presa para frenar
el avance de las fuerzas rusas pero
desde Estados Unidos dicen que kiev no
podría hacerle eso a su propio pueblo
qué razones entonces tienen ambas partes
para causar un daño de estos
Bueno yo cuando uno estudia la guerra a
través del tiempo yo nunca eximo ninguna
de las partes o a los adversarios que
están en el campo de batalla de no ser
capaces de cualquier cosa es decir este
yo habría que tener pruebas de quién
realmente fue pero en Las Guerras a
través del tiempo uno se da cuenta que
los actores que están en conflicto en el
campo de batalla pues han demostrado a
través del tiempo ser capaces de
cualquier cosa incluso de cometer actos
de lesa humanidad o crímenes de lesa
humanidad con tal de acusar a la
contraparte y ganar de alguna manera
cierta cierta validez ante la opinión
pública entonces aquí es muy complicado
determinar realmente quién fue
obviamente desde el año pasado Ya se
venía diciendo de alguna manera que
Rusia tener a Mira el asunto de La
Represa Y si uno se va un poco en la
historia uno se da cuenta también que en
el pasado principalmente en 1941
stalin ya había destruido en algún
momento algunas represas sobre todo
también en la región de saporilla para
frenar el avance tropas circlarianas que
habían tratado de conquistar a través de
Ucrania el territorio ruso en la Segunda
Guerra Mundial entonces un poco la
historia también cuando uno uno ve
algunos aspectos claves pues uno podría
apelar en algún momento de que este
mismo esquema o esta misma estrategia
podría estarse utilizando o repitiéndose
casi de forma igual con la manera en
como se está desarrollando este
conflicto entre Rusia y entre Rusia y
Ucrania en el territorio ucraniano ahora
que riesgos puede traer esta situación
para la población ucraniana muy
brevemente por favor bueno evidentemente
tiene que ver este muchos muchos de los
campos ya han sido inundados porque
estamos hablando de millones de metros
cúbicos de agua que han sido liberados
con la voladura y evidentemente pues hay
una una gran preocupación porque se está
hablando de que se tienen que evacuar
hasta casi 50.000 personas así que bueno
Lamentablemente la población civil es la
que sigue estando en medio de este
conflicto de la que sigue sufriendo
Lamentablemente las consecuencias de
esta guerra